Melbourne has been the most livable
city in the world for
the past seven years.
But this year it lost
the top spot to Vienna.
Home to Strauss and
Schubert and famous for its
coffee houses, Vienna scored
an almost perfect 99.1%.
But what makes a city livable?
The Economist intelligence
unit has been analyzing this.
It has ranked 140 cities
according to stability,
education, healthcare, infrastructure,
and culture and environment.
Most livable cities tend
to be mid sized in wealthy
countries and with low
population densities.
Copenhagen is the only other
European city in the top 10.
Australia and Canada each have
three cities and Japan two.
Western Europe and North America are
the most livable regions in the world.
The Middle East and Africa the least.
While asia and Australasia
are home to some
of the world's most livable
and unlivable cities.
Many factors impact how livable a city
is like natural disasters.
Hurricanes Irma and Maria destroyed much
of Puerto Rico this year.
The capital San Juan fell further
in rank than any other city.
The ending of Ivory Coast's
13 year UN peacekeeping
mission demonstrated a
step toward stability
and a steady increase in its livability.
The rankings of cities
like Damascus, Lagos,
Karachi, and Tripoli
show the extent to which
conflict contributes to
low livability scores.
And Caracas, the least
livable city in Latin America,
is only set to get worse
owing to the deepening
economic crisis and rising
authoritarianism in Venezuela.
Mega cities like London,
Paris, and New York have high
levels of crime, congestion,
and public transport problems
which keep them out of the top spots.
This year the world overall has become
a better place to live.
This is because of the
decrease in terrorism threats,
specifically in western Europe.
Vienna's increased stability is what has
given it the edge this year.